it is very clear to me that over the
next 15 years
what the blockchain will do especially
in the nft form on top of ethereum
is create
a world that will eat up all of the
contracts
all of them every contract
over the next 15 to 25 years will be
done on the blockchain
now that doesn't eliminate the need for
what we do here but it definitely
requires for you to understand it
you've got your perspective
[Applause]
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
morning atlanta
[Music]
[Applause]
it's uh it's really really nice to be
with all of you um
i don't have a ton of time on stage so
because i got to run to the meet and
greets so i want to really get into a
bunch of things that are on my mind for
this sector try to bring as much value
as i can while we're together
i you know i think much like two years
ago
when i was here how many people were
here for that
thank you
you know it's really interesting
there's i really play in two very
opposite places when it comes to
business life philosophy all of it
really which is
so much of what i do and think about and
what i admire and see in others is a
remarkable level of consistency of what
is truly tried and true
and then on the complete other extreme
part
i really spend almost all my time trying
to understand the one thing that
connects to everybody in this room
regardless of what they're trying to
achieve
whether you're in this room and under
the context of this room
you're clearly trying to achieve
something from a professional lens
but the reality is is
if you're passionate about fundraising
for your kids school or if you want to
segue your career or if you've got a
side hustle or if you
decide to pivot or run for public office
there's just such a fascinating thing
that has always been true
which is attention is the asset and how
you feel that attention
becomes the variable of what happens
you know i was born in the soviet union
and came to the u.s when i was three
and grew up in the 80s during the cold
war
and i've always wondered if
because of that i've always had an extra
interest
in the media
in propaganda in communication because
that was so much the warfare of the
soviet union in the u.s and obviously i
don't have to explain to anybody in this
room i think over the last half decade
our society has started paying a lot
more attention to
communication i was always fascinated by
why if there was a coup in a country
would they go to the tv station and the
newspapers even before they went to the
palace and it made me always understand
that this shit's important
communication is the variable
what's really fascinating about
this industry and i've many friends in
it is
when trying to grow the business
most of the dna in this room is sales
dna
it's not brand dna
you're not marketing you're selling it's
why google does so well it's why so many
people here feel comfortable allocating
money to google adwords because it's
transactional somebody types something
in
you spend dollars on it you go to the
top you see and feel the roi
very quickly i understand it i love
selling stuff it's
very easy to understand it's very easy
to invest in
what's impossibly difficult to invest in
is brand
it's hard
why am i wearing these
because a brand
nobody knocked on my [ __ ] door and
said do you want to buy these nikes
nobody i didn't type in nike into it and
this is brand this little swoosh is
worth a trillion dollars
a trillion
and so i think about that because it's
easier to understand with nike but it's
harder for a lot of people in this room
to think about it from their business
lens though we see it
many of you know many of you have your
faces on billboards and ads and
newspapers and things that nature
i believe in all that
i just don't believe in overpaying for
yesterday
and not investing in today
like whatever you did to get here
was about attention
whether it was shaking hands and having
friends and working the local thing
whether word of mouth is just attention
you did something for craig he liked it
enough and when sally asked him he
referred it's all just the same game the
problem is and the thing that i have had
an enormous amount of passion on
is if attention is the asset that grows
everything that creates the result
why aren't people interested
in investing
the 20 hours
that it would take to understand the
current
space of attention
like
i just don't understand why you wouldn't
see through the curiosity and spend five
hours
to understand why
a tick-tock video might actually lead to
a customer
i don't understand why you would say no
i let me rephrase i very much understand
why you say no
you say no because you positioned it in
your head as something else you've
positioned it as the thing that your
kids spend all their time on
right but what you don't do is the
homework that makes you understand that
over the last 18 months the growth of 35
to 55 year olds on tick tock is so
extraordinary we haven't seen growth of
consumption like that since 2011
facebook
all of a sudden if you understand that
truth it at least leads to the curiosity
how many people here are producing three
pieces of tick-tock video a day for
their business and if you raise your
hand i'm gonna check on stage publicly
so don't lie
how many people in this entire room make
three tick tock videos a day for their
company raise your hands
two
i'm sorry three sorry sally
three
three i love it and i love the passion
of that
what excites me about that is
because i've been making content about
tiktok for two and a half years i
already have dozens of emails from
lawyers
contractors
a cement provider hit me up last week
that he landed a big contract from a
tick tock
do you know how insane it sounds to even
say that a cement provider
landed a six-figure contract from a
tick-tock
even for me as progressive and curious
and in it as i am i understand how
far-fetched that may feel but it's a
reality and this isn't a talk to say
everybody run out and go make tick-tocks
this is a talk of are you challenging
yourself to do branding work
because it's the singular thing
that grows
anything
branding is the singular thing that
grows anything it's just the way the
world works and so i think the
opportunity is extraordinary
uh
one more time by show of hands by show
of hands
how many people
produce
two original videos or written articles
a day on linkedin raise your hand
one
one two got you two
again
that one
i struggle with way more but it goes
back to my only interest in this talk
today
why
are we the world this is not just this
sector this is the world why
are we not interested in putting in the
20 to 30 hours
to understand
something that's happening today
linkedin for the last four years has
converted itself into being the business
facebook this is not the linkedin we all
grew up with linkedin marketing isn't
spamming people on email it is making
content to go in the feed how many
people here consume content on linkedin
and know what i'm referring to raise
your hands raise it high please i want
everybody's higher come on
look
that is the fun thing for me
almost half this room is consuming it
two people are making for it
it speaks to the thing i started this
talk with i believe this room is in the
sales business
and i believe if you can make the shift
to understanding that you need to be in
the marketing and brand business it's
the only thing that can substantially
double
triple
10x of business it's real it's what
happens it happens at every business
it's happened for the last 20 years as
we've lived through
the internet revolution
this is important talk
for a much more important reason for
this specific room
the reason it's an important talk for
this room is if you became
an operator of contemporary marketing
for your business in this room
you would start the process
of changing your perspective
on how you navigate your business life
which is about to become unbelievably
important to everybody in this room
because of the advent of the blockchain
as
we are going into this next tier i think
all of us looking around this room
meant this is a perfect age demo for the
most part of many people either
never knowing anything else or the
majority of the room based on what i see
many of us remembering the world before
the internet
and watching what it's done over the
last 25 years to change our society
how many people here made it through
high school
without being on the internet raise your
hands i'll raise mine raise it high
that's right kids it sucked
so it's a lot of hands in this room we
recall
the world changed a lot
the world's changed a lot in the last 25
years the biggest companies the world
changed consumer behaviors changed the
way we buy things has changed the
decisions we make changed
and now we have
decentralized servers brewing and i'm
sure at this point especially because
this has been the year of nfts and
bitcoin
most people at this point have heard
of the blockchain bitcoin nfts but i'm
also empathetic that most people have
not spent their 20 to 50 hours to really
understand it but let me give you a
simple statement that i genuinely
believe will be true and i think has a
lot to do with this industry
if one is to understand the blockchain
and in 1995 when i saw the internet i
realized that my dad's one liquor store
needed to be an internet retailer
because that's how i was going to help
my family business and even though i
didn't own a computer i launched one of
the first e-commerce businesses and then
i did it again with social and that's
kind of how i've navigated
it is very clear to me that over the
next 15 years
what the blockchain will do especially
in the nft form on top of ethereum
is create
a world that will eat up all of the
contracts
all of them every contract
over the next 15 to 25 years will be
done on the blockchain
now that doesn't eliminate the need for
what we do here but it definitely
requires for you to understand it
and so for me
this talk is kind of really interesting
because it reminds me of a talk
a little bit of a different timing but i
gave a talk
to the limo
and car industry
right as uber was happening and the
majority of my talk was about uber in
the first 15 minutes and as you can
imagine the crowd didn't like it
um
and i was telling them that i was
concerned because the iphone had become
the remote control of our society and
now it really is
and that i thought it was dangerous
and people pooh-poohed it they said
that
legally it wouldn't happen or this
wouldn't happen or why would people
people like
like the way it feels to dr oh excuse
after excuse after excuse
and i'm sure everybody realizes how
much uber has changed that industry
i remember talking because i had a wine
store in 1995 and fell in love with the
internet as this is going to be big and
legitimately had two separate
conversations at the new jersey chamber
of commerce event in springfield new
jersey
in 1996 with two bookstore owners who
completely pooh-poohed amazon
i mean amazon probably sold more books
in the last hundredth of a second than
those two businesses combined did in
five years
we are very very very good of having
opinions
based on our own financial self-interest
my friends you are sitting how many
people here are retiring within the next
10 years and i don't before you raise
your hands
because the lady that threw her hand up
quick is exactly i mean fast you threw
that up fast
let me get this next part out i don't
mean you're gonna crush it
and buy an island i mean you're old and
you're finished
raise your hands 10 years raise it high
just want to get a sense
all right so there's about 7 to 15
for the rest of you that are not
retiring in what you do for a living
you have a choice to make
in one man's humble point of view
that could be quite remarkable in my
opinion
you
are in an industry that collaterally is
going to be massively affected by the
blockchain
because of how peer-to-peer contracts
are going to work
which takes a lot
of things in the middle
out of the equation
this doesn't have to be bad
much like i told my friend
who was in the medallion business in la
i said you could invest in uber
you could do this you could build a
fleet and build a business development
thing
this isn't about technology
putting people out of business everybody
always thinks about it too extreme there
will be lawyers even with the blockchain
doing everything you're doing for the
rest of everyone's career here
the opportunity though
to completely change the trajectory of
your career and gain extraordinary
market share because you actually
understand
what's going on with ethereum or solana
or decentralization or the sec's point
of view on this is it a royalty is it a
collateral is it an asset
is stunning
in i'm one human being
and in the last and yes i'm in it but
i'm one human
in the last six weeks i've had
multiple dozens which is a lot one
person
dozens of friends asking for legal
and tax help
with the
aggressive behavior in a positive for
them of buying nfts and what do they do
and how do they navigate
i just want you to make linkedin posts
and tick tocks because i think your
business will grow better than the stuff
you're doing with your time and money
now
i am
far more motivated that just three
people from this talk
i'm at the point of my career where i'm
here for a singular reason for three of
you to email me in five years and say i
don't know if you remember in 2021 in
atlanta you gave that talk and i took it
serious and i'm now this that feels nice
i like that that's how i roll now and so
i'm telling this room
this is really happening
like really and the opportunity is
extraordinary this isn't a fear combo of
like be careful this is an optimism
combo of do you understand how big this
is do you understand just like what the
internet did to our society over the
next 25 years
decentralized servers that scare scale
are going to completely change the world
let me ask you a common sense question
if this was some small [ __ ]
do you think china would ban it
my friends this is big big
this is the single biggest thing that
has happened since the internet itself
social media was a monster thing in the
middle
because communication dictates
everyone's decisions
it was big that's why committed to it
but this blockchain thing for this
industry is extraordinarily big because
it's going to touch it fast
and so i would highly recommend people
spend their 20 to 50 hours
to get educated on what ethereum is and
what a smart contract looks like
because i have a funny feeling if you
actually do not just write it on a piece
of paper right now and then never
actually do anything about it
if you actually put in the 20 to 50
hours i think there's a ton
of gold at the end of that rainbow
more importantly you have five years to
go on offense with what i'm talking
about
if you do nothing in that five years
your year six through ten is gonna be
defense on it
and that's what always happens
so that's the big elephant in the room
slash opportunity
the other
really interesting part is how do you
get your marketing game up to grow your
business
and
i think that sits in a very interesting
place of
the common mistake of the last decade
of companies of this size entrepreneurs
executives
individuals in this room of this size
has been to outsource that behavior
without being able to judge if it's good
the reason a lot of you have your
opinion on social
is because you hired your niece or
someone that sucked but you had no idea
how to judge it
the roi of a basketball
for lebron james is a billion dollars
the roi of a basketball for me is
negative eight thousand dollars i've
torn both my knees
the roi of social media is in the
trillions
if it hasn't worked for you it's because
you don't know how to use it
20 to 50 hours
i don't know if you've heard there's a
site that can really help you get
educated i'll give it to you i'll let
you write it down it's g
how does a lawyer make linkedin content
that works for their business enter
how do i make a podcast that brings me
business enter
the
world is very obvious right now
everything because of technology on a
daily basis is getting commoditized
besides the human aspect
and communication
your ability to communicate to your
potential customers is singularly the
variable of your upside if i'm able to
just use this time together
to get you to realize you've been in
sales mode even when you've been doing
marketing
and that or when you've been doing
marketing in the past and obviously
everyone here does different things
that the modern version of it
is just more effective for the cost the
problem is people don't want to make the
investment into the cost of creative
people don't want to invest in the
videos and the pictures they want to run
the ads because they're custom from
google well you just run math right you
just run the ads it's just words
in social the world we live in now the
ad matters
whether that stars you or it doesn't the
creative is the variable of success
linkedin ads work ridiculously well for
lawyers
but there are thousands of lawyers that
have emailed me over the last five years
that have gotten no roi
and the 13 times i've looked at the link
that they sent me in those 10 000 emails
it's because the ad sucks
it's because they're awkward on video
it's because it wasn't compelling it's
because
it was
somebody trying to throw a right hook
without setting up a jab
this is about bringing value to the
other person on the other side
you guys have so much knowledge you can
make videos of just information what ifs
you could do what if scenarios in video
form for the rest of your life you've
seen it
you've been through it that what if
is a piece of information that might
make the other person feel a little more
comfortable that you're not just trying
to sell them
consumers are used to television ads for
lawyers that have phone numbers that is
spam and direct response creative
the opportunity is enormous
we continue for some reason to
disrespect technology
i'd really prefer you don't
it makes absolutely no business sense
whatsoever
your ideology has nothing to do with the
way you run your business
people are like well gary i don't buy
stuff from facebook ads i'm like that's
great harold
but [ __ ] three billion people do dick
well gary i don't like facebook it's
fake i'm like cool
do you like your business
like what's the matter with people
if this room doesn't figure out ethereum
fast or if ethereum becomes friendster
and something later became facebook for
social media
if you don't understand the concept of
smart contracts on decentralized
blockchain it will affect your business
the next 10 years the seven people that
raise their hands you can chill a little
bit because you're gonna be golfing and
drinking margaritas the rest of you need
to really focus on 20 to 50 hours of
curiosity and homework stop making
assumptions
i love everybody has an opinion on nfts
that they're a scam or they're beanie
babies or it's a fad without doing an
hour of homework
we have become a headline reading hot
take society that's a bad strategy for
actual business i think you should
change it and i hope these
minutes together at least gave you uh a
little something to push it through and
i appreciate all of you so much i wish
you well thank you
thank you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this
is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon